here's a good story from coindesk it
says a non-fungible token nft of twitter
founder jack dorsey's first ever tweet
could sell for just under 280 dollars
which is still
280 too much
but the current owner of the nft listed
it for 48 million dollars last week
iranian-born crypto entrepreneur cena
estavi purchased the nft
of the tweet for i think we have it
there
yep that's so that's the tweet there
it's it's jack the first ever tweet and
he's saying just setting up my twitter
that's the tweet now
he purchased this tweet for three
million dollars
in march of last year and now he's
trying to sell it and he was offered 280
bucks for it
now
200 280 million dollars is uh you know
rather 2.9 million dollars almost 3
million dollars
maybe just a slightly overpriced because
i can have that tweet for free
like just i could take that tweet and
screenshot it and i you got it for three
million dollars i got it for nothing
and we both have exactly the same thing
which is an image of this tweet which is
not worth anything
i mean this this um
as i've been saying about nfts i think
this
kind of drives the point home
um when when the when the value can
depreciate that quickly
it kind of shows you that
uh the v the value for an entity is
totally artificial
these are as i've said it's they're
basically beanie babies digital bean
babies but a lot but but a lot more
worthless than beanie babies because at
least beanie babies are physical things
that you can take ownership and
possession of
and at least if i you know if i buy a
beanie baby
and there may be many that look like it
but i actually have this physical beanie
baby and no one else has it i have this
one
no one else has the exact same one
so
maybe i could take some comfort in that
at least
but if i have the digital image of a
beanie baby then anyone can have
exactly the same thing and it doesn't
even exist
so totally artificial value
it's based on nothing at all other than
just the whims of
people who are into buying nfts
and that's especially precarious in a
country where
the whims change so often
so because of the whims of nft
collectors
last year that tweet went for almost
three million
a year later they just said oh yeah you
know what i don't we don't feel like
pretending that that's worth anything
this time instead we're pretending that
this that these things are worth
something
[Music]
not exactly the smartest investment
strategy i would say if you enjoyed this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up and
share it with all your friends